Catherine snow says her mother-in-law
Charlene went to the Cape Breton
Regional Hospital Emergency Department
on December 30th snow says the
67-year-old hadn't been feeling well for
a few days and arrived at the ER with
intense jaw pain and flu-like symptoms
we're pretty sure she was triaged and
she waited for seven hours but it just
became too uncomfortable for her and she
decided that she would leave and try her
luck at the local
um the local Outpatient Clinic uh the
next morning but she never made it to
that clinic snow says her heart stopped
just an hour after she returned home
snow was clear sharing Charlene's story
is about getting answers and not placing
blame it would be reassuring for us if
we knew that everything was done that
could have been done
um and and if not we want to know why
veteran ER physician Robert Martel says
the community's trust in the system is
eroding especially after the recent
death of Allison holthoff who waited
seven hours for Care at an Amherst
Hospital people have to feel that they
can trust their system to care for them
when they need it Martel adds a start to
alleviating strain on emergency rooms
would be revisiting the triage system if
you were going to do triage
the way I believe it should be done the
front end of that triage should be a
physician uh with the ability to
discharge an individual order tests
Etc in a statement Health Minister
Michelle Thompson confirms an
investigation is underway into
Charlene's case and assures Nova
scotians any recommendations will be
acted on snow says she won't give up I'm
a stay-at-home mom I did not think I
would be sitting in this chair yesterday
morning advocating
provincially for better health care but
I'll do it for my mother-in-law and I'll
do it for my daughter who's missing her
man she's launched a new website
encouraging Nova scotians with similar
experiences to share their stories
Sky bride and Blom Global News hellofax